How's the weather today, Mom?
It's rainy.
Put on your raincoat and rain boots.
Okay, Mom.
Can I put on my pink dress today?
No, you'd better put on your jacket and pants.
It's cold and windy outside.
Then I'll put on my dress and a warm coat.
How, how, how, how does a clown put on a face?
First, she puts on white face paint, white face paint.
Next, she paints around her mouth and paints her eyelids.
Next, she puts on big eyebrows, and paints big circles on her cheeks.
Next, she puts on her red nose. It honks if you squeeze it.
After putting on a red nose, she puts on a silly wig.
Then she puts on a polka-dot jacket, striped pants, floppy shoes.
Now, it is time to make kids laugh!